>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress, in Washington D.C.
>> Speaker 2: Norse law has remained
unchanged for 10,000 years and
yet you seek to change it today.
Over my dead body [growling]!
>> Speaker 3: Norse law states
that every Viking must
eat the food of the gods.
>> Speaker 4: Falafel
is no food of the gods.
>> Speaker 2: No.
>> Speaker 3: It's
pronounced falafel.
>> Speaker 5: Falafel
is not even meat.
>> Speaker 3: Have
you ever tried one?
It's delicious!
>> Speaker 6: And the tahini sauce,
it literally melts in your mouth.
>> Speaker 5: I only
trust what I can kill.
>> Speaker 6: You don't
need to kill the falafel.
It's vegan.
>> Speaker 2: What did you call me?
[ Arguing ]
>> Speaker 3: Magnus Chase, son
of Frey eats falafel every day
and we know this because we
are told in this shiny book.
>> Speaker 5: Shiny book.
>> Speaker 3: Now who here dares
defy the words of Magnus Chase?
>> Speaker 2: Falafel is cool.
>> Speaker: 7: I ate
some last night.
>> Speaker 3: Magnus Chase and
the Gods of Asgard, book three,
The Ship of the Dead,
from Rick Riordan.
>> Speaker 2: Now this is delicious.
>> Speaker 8: And it's gluten free!
>> Speaker 2: What did you call me?
[ Arguing ]
>> Speaker 9: Mr. Rick Riordan!
[ Cheers ]
>> Rick Riordan: Hew everybody!
Wow, well that was something.
I don't know about you guys, I'm
hungry for falafel now [laughter].
Anybody else?
Well it's fantastic to be here.
Do we have a clicker up here
for the little thingy bobber?
Yeah. Oh, thank you.
What happened to your hair?
Well, it's great to be
back, it's wonderful.
Thanks to everybody for coming out.
Are you guys missing class for this?
>> [crowd response] Yes!
>> Rick Riordan: Ah, I'm so sorry.
What a terrible thing.
So I should try to talk really,
really fast to get you guys
back as soon as possible?
No?
>> [crowd response] No!
>> Rick Riordan: Okay, whatever.
Well, it's great to be
here and as you heard
in the introduction I was
a teacher for many years
so I always liked field trips
and I'm glad you guys
could join me today.
I was thinking backstage,
it has been 40 years
since I started writing.
Can you believe that?
I am 53 now, which I can't believe,
but I started writing when I was 13.
I was in eighth grade and I wrote
this story for my English teacher
about this guy who dies and
he goes into the afterlife.
It was like a fantasy story.
My teacher read it and she said,
"Rick, this is really good.
Why don't we see if we
can get it published?"
And I was like, "You can do that?"
I didn't know how you
got things published.
This was before the Internet;
we didn't have fan fiction,
we didn't have What Pad, we
didn't have social media.
If you wanted to get something
published you just kind of had
to send it to a magazine
or a publisher
in New York and hope they liked it.
So we sent off this story.
I was so excited and finally,
after about six weeks,
I got back a rejection and that
was only the first rejection.
I kept writing, I kept writing
and I got rejected for
everything I put in.
It wasn't until I was 30 years
old that I finally got published.
I wrote a novel for adults
called Big Red Tequila.
It was a murder mystery.
I was teaching middle
school at the time;
I don't think that's why
I was contemplating murder
but I'm not sure [laughter].
But I sent it off and
it got published.
But even after that, I was still
teaching for another ten years,
and I loved teaching, I didn't
mind that, but I was writing books
and teaching at the same time.
It wasn't until my son was in the
second grade and having trouble
in school and I started telling him
Greek myths for bedtime stories,
that I started thinking hey,
you know what, I teach kids,
I write books, why don't I
put the two things together?
And it finally made sense to me.
And out of those stories about
Greek mythology came the story
of Percy Jackson.
My very first book, The
Lightning Thief, which I hear some
of you guys have read, and the
question was pretty simple.
What would you do if you
found out that your real mom
or your real dad was a Greek god?
Yeah, I see the wheels
spinning, right?
You're thinking about it.
Uh huh. That'd be pretty cool?
Yeah. Would anybody have
a favorite Greek god?
Who would you like
as your mom or dad?
Let me see some hands.
Who would you choose?
Aphrodite, the goddess of love;
Aphrodite had a magical belt
and she could make any guy fall
in love with her like that.
That'd be cool.
I'm sure that's not why
you would want [inaudible]
but that's a pretty cool power.
Yeah, who would you
like as a mom or a dad?
>> Speaker 10: Zeus.
>> Rick Riordan: Zeus!
The god of the sky.
If anybody bothered you
you could be like, hey dad,
this guy right here, boom!
Lightening, not bad.
Over here, yes?
Artemis, ah, the huntress.
She would be really cool.
You'd be great at bows and arrows
and you could live
outside all the time.
Of course, Artemis said she would
never have kids but, you know.
Maybe you could be
adopted or something.
That'd be cool.
My favorite answer, I was at a
school one time and I said, okay,
who would you like as a god if
you had a mom or a dad as a god.
A kid raised his hand
and said, "Batman!"
I was like yes, excellent answer.
All right, well anyway.
Hands down.
That was Percy Jackson.
I wrote five books about
Percy and I loved it
and I thought I was pretty much done
with Greek mythology but the thing
about myths and stories is the
more you read is the more you find.
So I kept finding more
stories and so I, yes,
you've got the first
book right there.
I started the Heroes
of Olympus series
and the first book
was the Lost Hero.
Five more of those and now
I've written, like, yeah,
it's about 20 books for kids.
That's crazy!
And today, the weird thing
is, after all of these years
from the time I was 13 and I wrote
that story about a guy who dies
and goes into the afterlife, I'm
here with you today to tell you
about the newest book, which is
about a guy who dies and goes
into the afterlife
[laughter], Magnus Chase.
The Vikings believed that if
you died a hero with a sword
or some other weapon in your
hand, doing what was right
and defending your friends and
being courageous, being a hero,
if you died like that
you would go to Valhalla,
which was like paradise
for warriors.
You would be one of Odon's chosen,
the [foreign language
spoken], the loan warriors.
And you would be indestructible
almost.
You would fight with Odon on
[inaudible], the day of doom.
Well Magnus Chase is a kid
living on the streets of Boston.
One day he finds this magical
sword, defends a bunch of people
from this monster and in the
very first chapter Magnus dies.
And he wakes up and
he's in Valhalla.
He's a modern [foreign language
spoken], one of Odon's warriors.
Which is pretty cool except if
he ever goes outside of Valhalla
and goes on, like, adventures
he can die out there but if he's
in Valhalla he can't die.
They can go around
Valhalla, they have swords,
they're cutting each
other's heads off
and they just get right
back up again.
They have a big battle every day.
Everybody goes out and it's like
a game of freeze tag or it's
like a game of dodge ball
except with swords [laughter].
And it doesn't matter
how many times you die,
the next morning you'll just wake up
in your bed and you're totally fine.
Do not try this at home, okay,
this is only in Valhalla.
Anyway, Magnus Chase, what can I
tell you about the newest book?
Well, since there are nine wolds
in Norse mythology we are going
on nine different adventures.
You guys are the very first ones.
We're starting with you in
D.C, and then we're going all
across the company
to different places,
eight cities in eight
days from here.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
In the newest book, The Ship of the
Dead, Magnus has a little problem.
Are you familiar with loki?
>> [crowd response] Yes.
>> You've seen the Thor movies?
>> Yeah, that's not exactly how he
is in mythology but he is a pretty,
pretty clever, tricky villain.
Well, Loki was punished
in Norse mythology.
When the gods got mad at him
because he killed this other god
and gods can die in Norse mythology.
They took Loki and they tied him
down in a cave, like spread eagle,
like this on the floor
for all eternity.
But that wasn't gross enough.
They didn't just tie
him down with chains,
the gods turned Loki's two
favorite sons into wolves
and made them fight
each other to the death
and then they took the entrails,
the intestines, I'm sorry,
did you guys eat before you came?
They took the intestines of Loki's
sons and made magical chains
and chained him down with those
but even that wasn't gross enough.
They took a big stone pillar
and put it by his head
and they took a giant serpent
and wound it around the pillar
and the serpent, all day
long for all eternity,
would drip poison into Loki's eyes.
Can you imagine what
that would feel like?
>> [crowd response] No.
>> The only help he had, his wife,
the goddess Sigyn, she had a bowl
and she would kneel at Loki's
side and collect the acid in a cup
but every once in awhile she
would have to empty the cup.
So she would turn and empty it and
during that time the acid would fall
in Loki's eyes and Loki
would writhe and scream.
Aaahh! And that's why the Vikings
thought earthquakes happened.
It was Loki in his chains
under the mountain doing that.
Well, in this book, The Ship
of the Dead, Loki has escaped.
He is finally out and you can
imagine he's not real happy.
He has gone to find the ship
of the dead, which is the boat
that he will take to sail to
doomsday, the final battle,
when all nine worlds burn
and the gods will die.
It's a really happy time [laughter].
This ship of the dead is made,
it's called the ship of nails
and that's not because it has a
bunch of nails hammered in it,
we're talking toenails
and fingernails [moans].
The entire ship, big enough
for a million warriors,
is cobbled together from
the toenails and fingernails
of all the dead warriors
from all time.
How gross is that?
And that's why the Vikings
believed that when you died,
you better get somebody to trim
your nails because if you died
with long nails you
were contributing
to the ship of the dead.
So that's what Magnus
has in store for him,
a whole bunch of toenails
and a really angry god.
He's got to go on this big journey
to try to find out where Loki is
to stop him before he
can start doomsday.
Some of the characters
that you will learn more
about if you have read
the series already,
you may remember Hearthstone
the elf,
he is the MVE, most valuable elf.
He is from [inaudible],
the world of the elves,
and a few things are really cool
about Hearthstone, he's deaf;
he uses sign language but he also
is an amazing roon stone magician.
He can take these roon stones and
make different things happen simply
by throwing them into the air like
one roon stone will create a horse
that has eight legs and
can ride through the air.
Another roon stone will create a
barrier of ice that no one can get
through and he's got 27 different
roon stones so he's got a lot
of things, literally, in his bed.
Thomas Jefferson Junior,
he lives in Valhalla.
HE died a hero but he died in 1863.
He was a member of the
54th Massachusetts regimen,
one of the first African-American
units to fight for the union,
and he died in battle and
he is now there in Valhalla,
one of Magnus's best friends.
And he is a great fighter,
he will go on the adventure.
You'll find out a little
bit more about him.
Thomas Jefferson Junior
is a great guy,
he's a great warrior,
he's very strong.
He does have this strange thing
about wanting to charge up hills.
I'm not sure what that's about;
it's a Civil War thing I guess.
You'll also find out about Mallory
Keen, who's a great fighter.
She died a hero in the 1970s in
Ireland trying to disarm a car bomb
and you'll hear how that
happened in the book.
Halfborn Gunderson,
another one of our friends.
He's a berserker.
Have you ever heard of berserkers?
>> [crowd response] Yes.
>> Rick Riordan: They are
warriors from the Viking days
that they would go into
this sort of trance
and usually they didn't
wear armor, they just had,
like, an ax and that's it.
Sometimes they didn't wear
anything but just like underpants.
That was it.
And they would paint themselves
different colors and they would go
into this massively
weird, frenzied state.
You couldn't even talk to
them when they were like that.
You just sort of point them
at the enemy and say go.
And they would charge into battle
and while they were
berserking they felt no pain.
They would just charge into
battle and kill anybody they say.
[Screams] like that.
So, if you ever hear the term
you're going berserk that's
where it comes from.
You're like a bersekrer,
you're charging into battle.
And so you'll find out a
little bit more about him.
And one of my favorite
characters, Alex Fierro.
Alex was introduced
in the last book.
Alex is a great character.
Alex is the child of Loki,
the evil trickster god
but that doesn't necessarily
mean Alex is evil.
Alex has an interesting past.
Alex is gender fluid, which means
that on some days Alex identifies
as male, on some days
Alex identifies as female
and if you get it wrong
on one day or the other,
Alex will let you know about it.
And you're just supposed to, you
know, kind of go with it and sort
of know whether it's sort of a
female or a male day for Alex.
Anyway, Alex has this ceramics
tool and it's just like a wire
and not only can she cut ceramics
with it but she can also sort
of fling it and cut the
heads off of dragons,
you know, her friends, whatever.
The thing about Alex that was kind
of cool was recently, in fact,
that book where she was
introduced, I'm going to say she
because normally Alex introduces
as female [applause] won
the Stonewall Book Award,
which is really cool.
If you don't know what that is, it's
a book for, it's an award for book
that have characters that are
lesbian, bisexual, gay, transgender,
that are in the LGBT spectrum.
And you don't see a
lot of characters
like that in children's books.
Alex is and so I was really honored
that because of Alex's presence
in the book it got
the Stonewall Award.
And, of course, you'll
see Alex again.
So, that's enough about Magnus.
What else is going on with me?
Well, as you heard earlier,
I get a lot of questions
from people saying
are you ever going
to write about Aztec mythology?
What about Chinese mythology?
What about Nigerian mythology?
What about Native American
mythology?
And there are so many
amazing mythologies out there
but the thing is, a lot of those I
didn't grow up with the way I grew
up with Egyptian and
Norse, and Greek and Roman.
I know those pretty well.
I taught them, I grew up with them.
But Brazilian mythology, I
mean I'm sure it's amazing
but I don't know anything about it.
So I started thinking, instead
of me writing all these books,
wouldn't it be better to find an
author who is from that background,
who knows those myths, and who is an
expert in the way that I can't be.
And instead of me writing the book,
finding somebody who wants to write
that book, who is from that
background, and promote them.
And so that's what
we're going to do.
We have an imprint, which
is like just a subsection
of Disney Publishing,
called Rick Riordan Presents
and the first book is going
to come out very soon.
It's coming out in March.
It's called Aru Shah and the End
of Time and it's by Roshani Chokshi
and that's here, that's the cover.
I have to say, I love
Hindu mythology.
I don't know if you know
anything about Hindu mythology.
They have hundreds of gods.
You think Greek mythology
is complicated, whoa.
Hindu mythology is amazing
and she does a great job,
all these different magic spells
and different gods and adventures
and it's a pretty incredible book.
It's coming out in March
and then, in the fall,
we're going to do a book called The
Storm Runner by Jennifer Cervantes,
which is based on Mayan mythology.
And, again, if you don't know
anything about Mayan mythology,
neither did I but after reading
this book it's pretty amazing.
I'm glad I wasn't a Mayan
because there's some bloody,
bloody stuff that happens.
And also, a book on Korean
mythology called The Dragon Pearl
by an author named Yoon
Ha Lee that's going
to be coming out in the fall.
And we're going to try
to do four books a year.
So if you're interested
in other mythologies,
hopefully this will give
you a look at those.
Also, I'm doing another series.
Has anybody read The
Trials of Apollo?
Yeah, good, I'm glad.
This is about Apollo, the god, and
he gets punished by his dad, Zeus,
and if you're punished I don't'
know what your parents do
if they make you stay in your room
or they take away TV or whatever,
with Apollo he's punished by being
turned into a human [laughter].
I didn't know Zeus could do that
but he strips away Apollo's magic
powers, dumps him down into Earth
and he lands in a dumpster
in Manhattan.
He's a regular 16-year-old
kid with no powers
and his name is Lester
Pappadapolous [laughter] and he has
to find his way back
to Mount Olympus
by doing all these
different adventures.
So anyway, the third book in
that series I'm working on now,
it'll be called The Burning
Maze and that comes out May 1st.
So stay tuned for that one.
The Kane Chronicles,
my Egyptian series.
We're putting out a new book
about the Kanes called The
Brooklyn House Magician's Guide.
So if you're interested in
finding out how magicians do magic,
how they cast spells and
charms and curses and all that
and all the different Egyptian
gods, this will be here for you.
And if you haven't read The Kane
Chronicles this is a good time
to pick them up because
they're getting a new look.
There's a sneak peek at the
new jackets that they'll have
that are coming out in April.
So check those out
if you like Egypt.
There's also a Magnus
Chase coloring book.
I know, right?
I, you know, I didn't
even think I would like,
they said they want
to do a coloring book.
Disney told me this, I'm
like, a coloring book?
And then I saw the pictures
and they're amazing.
I really like them.
The Lightning Thief coloring
book just came out last month
and it's been a lot of fun.
And this one's coming
out next year in August.
And, if you want to know more,
we're just launching a
website called readriordan.com.
The site has been around but it's
getting a major, major revamp.
Some of the stuff is already
up, some of it is coming soon,
but it will be the
official home for demigods.
For instance, you can find out
more about all the characters.
There will be quizzes online.
I know a lot of you
have asked about this.
How do I find out who
my godly parent is?
There's a quiz for that so you can
get on readriordan.com and find
out what's your magic weapon, who's
your godly parent and all of that.
You can decide what sort of
demigod you're going to be.
And a bunch of stuff about
locations that happened in the books
and social media, social art.
Anything you want to share,
Instagram stuff, Twitter stuff,
all of that will be there.
And let's not forget, the boy who
started it all, Percy Jackson.
What's going on in his world?
Some cool stuff has
happened recently.
In the summer it was turned
into a Broadway musical.
Off-Broadway Lightning Thief,
can you imagine Percy
dancing and singing?
[singing] Oh, I kill Minotaurs.
I don't know.
I have to admit, I haven't actually
seen the play and that's not
because it's not good;
it's supposed to be really,
really funny and really,
really good.
It's just, I have trouble
seeing adaptations;
it just kind of freaks me out a
little bit to see my characters
like that but they did a
great job and if you want
to hear Percy sing the soundtrack
is on iTunes, you can check it out.
And they're talking about doing
a touring version so, who knows,
fingers crossed, it'll come
to D.C. one of these days.
And, next year, there's
going to be a special edition
of The Lightning Thief coming out
fully illustrated by John Rocco,
who did the covers, every
single page color illustrations,
the whole book, all the way
through, this thing is beautiful.
And there's the cover.
It's just announced yesterday and
here's a little sneak peek inside.
I told you not to park there, rrrr!
A look at the cabins
of Camp Half Blood.
And [inaudible], the ferry man,
taking people across the underworld.
Nice. So you can look
forward to that in August.
So that's just a little
look at what's going on.
Now it's time to get
to my favorite part,
we're going to see what you guys
are interested in hearing about
and do a little Q and A. We're
going to get some from our audience
and we have our wonderful
helpers here who are going
to come out with microphones.
So if you have a question
you can raise your hand,
we'll get to as many as we can.
And we'll get some from
our online viewers as well.
>> Speaker 11: Who would you
want your godly parent to be?
>> Rick Riordan: Ah, who would
I want my godly parent to be?
I would hope for Athena but as
I was telling somebody earlier,
with my luck I'd probably
get someone
like Dionysis [phonetic], you know.
My power is I can summon
Diet Coke, hurray [laughter].
All right, a question
over on this side.
>> Speaker 12: Hold on one second.
>> Rick Riordan: Hold on.
Let's get you a microphone there.
There you go sweetheart.
>> Speaker 13: Here we go.
>> Speaker 14: Who is in this book?
>> Rick Riordan: The one
that I'm talking about today?
>> Speaker 14: Yes, the new book.
>> Rick Riordan: The new
book, The Ship of the Dead,
well it is Magnus Chase and
some of the other characters
that I showed you on the
screen like Alex and Mallory
and T.J. You'll also,
however, get a little look
at Percy Jackson and Anabeth Chase.
They make an appearance
in the book too.
So if you're wondering
what Percy is up to,
you can check that out in here too.
>> Speaker 15: Awesome.
Okay, right over here.
Tell us your name.
>> Speaker 16: I'm Lillian.
What's your favorite
kind of mythology?
>> Rick Riordan: Ah, thanks Lillian.
My favorite kind of mythology.
It's so hard to say,
I love them all.
I always keep coming back
to the Greek myths simply
because there are so many of them.
There's so much that
you can write about.
The other myths are
great but we don't have
as many myths written down.
I wish we did but we've lost a lot
of stories that were never written
down so I think the Greek just
because we know the most about it.
Yeah and back over here.
>> Speaker 16: When did your first
Lightning Thief book come out?
>> Rick Riordan: When did the first
Lightning Thief book came out, 2005,
2006-ish; 2006, my official
researcher down here told me, yeah.
So it's been just over 10 years.
>> Speaker 13: Say your name.
>> Speaker 15: Let's go back to the
back over here, Rick, to the left.
>> Rick Riordan: Oh, okay.
We'll get right to you.
>> Speaker 17: Are you
going to write a book
about what happened to Leo?
>> Rick Riordan: What
happened to Leo.
Actually, Leo is a character
in the Heroes of Olympus series
and in the trials of Apollo, you're
going to see all of the characters
from Percy Jackson and
Heroes of Olympus again
and in the second Trials of
Apollo series you will spend a lot
of time with Leo and Calypso.
So yeah, you'll find out there
what's going on with both of them.
Yeah.
>> Speaker 13: Okay, ready?
>> Rick Riordan: Okay,
yeah, go ahead.
Thanks for waiting.
>> Speaker 13: Say your name.
>> Speaker 18: Why isn't, well, you
know Loki's son is in your new book.
>> Rick Riordan: Right.
>> Speaker 18: Alex.
I thought he was going to be killed.
Like, why is, I thought
Loki's two sons were killed
and turned into wolves.
>> Rick Riordan: Ah, yes.
You're very observant.
That's right.
These are, you're just
talking about different sons.
Loki had a lot of children and some
of them were pretty interesting.
One of his kids was Fenris
Wolf, this giant wolf.
How does a god and a giant
have a kid who is a wolf?
I have no idea.
One of their other children was
[inaudible], the world serpent,
this huge snake that is so
big it wraps all the way
around the bottom of the ocean.
Again, how do you have
a kid who's a snake?
I don't know.
But these are just two other
kids we were talking about.
Great question!
>> Speaker 15: Awesome.
Okay, right here, tell us your name.
>> Speaker 19: Angelique.
Which mythology do
you know most about?
>> Rick Riordan: Hmm, I think
probably either Norse or Greek.
I grew up with both of those and
Egyptian so I think I know them
but I think I've known the Norse
mythology the longest because I was
into that when I was like in 7th
grade and, like I was talking
about earlier, we just have
more of the Greek myths
so I know a lot about those as well.
Yeah.
>> Speaker 15: Okay,
let's go right down here.
All right.
Tell us your name.
>> Speaker 20: Marcus.
Is this you [laughter]?
>> Speaker 15: Is that me?
That's Magnus.
This is me without the Magnus hair.
>> Rick Riordan: Marcus's question
was is the guy of the cover
of the Ship of the Dead actually
Seal, who is my publicist at Disney,
Seal is just being a good
sport and he's dressing
up as Magnus for the day, so.
We wouldn't want him to go off and
fight Fenriss Wolfe or anything.
>> Speaker 21: My name is Mary Ann
and which book is your favorite book
of all the books that
you've written?
>> Rick Riordan: Oh Mary Ann,
a great question and
so hard to answer.
I've got so many books.
I mean, obviously, the Lightning
Thief is really special to me
because it was my first children's
book and it's what started it all.
I think my favorite
Percy Jackson book
in the series is actually the Battle
of the Labyrinth, the fourth one.
I really like the battle
scene in that.
Favorite one of all time?
I don't know.
I really like the Magnus
Chase books, the Viking books.
Those gods and heroes and
monsters are just so weird.
I really like them.
>> Speaker 15: Okay, we're going
to the top up there to the right.
>> Rick Riordan: All right.
>> Speaker 22: We actually
have a question from one
of the schools that's tuning
in live on Youtube right now.
>> Rick Riordan: Fantastic.
>> Speaker 22: This is
Northwest Rankin Middle School
in Flowood, Mississippi.
So Jacy Errington, who
is in seventh grade,
wants to know did you every write
a book that made you almost want
to quit and, if so, what
was it and why [laughter]?
>> Rick Riordan: Yes, Jacy, that's
called every book [laughter].
No, just because, not really but,
I mean, writing books is hard.
Writing books is a lot of work and
I have, like I said, written what?
Like 20 books for kids or
something like that and 30 overall.
And I keep thinking it's
going to get easier.
It doesn't.
Every book is hard.
A lot of it is revising.
Do you guys have to
revise in school?
>> [crowd response] Yes.
>> Rick Riordan: Yeah, I know.
Do you hate that?
>> [crowd response] Yes.
>> Rick Riordan: Yeah, me too!
Me too. But here's the thing I found
out, it's just part of the deal.
No one can write a perfect
first draft with no mistakes.
It cannot be done.
I've written 30 books,
I still can't do it.
I have to revise every single
book three, four, five,
six times before I
get everything right.
So if you're going to write, it's
a great thing to do but you have
to be ready, you've to revise.
Part of the process.
>> Speaker 15: Okay, we're going to
go to Steph over here on the right.
>> Speaker 13: Okay, say your name.
>> Speaker 23: My name is Sasha
and my question is what was
the hardest series to make?
Like, how long did it take-
>> Rick Riordan: Yeah, sure.
>> Speaker 23: to make
the Magnus Chase?
>> Rick Riordan: Yeah,
yeah, I think, um,
probably the hardest one was the
Egyptian series, The Kane Chronicles
because we don't know a whole
lot about, well we know some
but there's still a lot about the
Egyptian gods that we don't know
and we have to sort of guess.
I found out that a lot of stuff
about how Egyptians
thought magic worked though.
We have a lot of Egyptian
spells that have come
down over the thousands of years and
that's kind of interesting so I went
to a lot of museums, I read a lot,
and I tried to recreate
how a magician
from Egypt would have
done their magic.
It's really pretty fascinating stuff
but it was very hard to research.
Thank you.
Good question.
>> Speaker 15: Okay, back
over here to the left, Rick.
>> Rick Riordan: Yeah.
>> Speaker 24: My name is Tallulah
and what is your favorite Greek god?
>> Rick Riordan: Favorite Greek god.
Would I surprise you if I
said Poseidon [laughter]?
I think that's why I made him
Percy's dad because I like the ocean
and I didn't want Percy's dad to
be Zeus, the most powerful god
because I just thought
that would be too obvious.
You know, everyone
wants to be Zeus's kid.
It's more interesting if he's
the second most powerful god,
gives him a little
bit more to work for.
>> Speaker 15: Tell us your name.
>> Speaker 25: My name is Madison.
My question is what's your
motivation for your books?
>> Rick Riordan: What's
my motivation for books?
Madison, I think probably my
motivation is deadlines [laughter].
I'm kidding but it's really
good to have a deadline.
I was talking about that with some
of the interviewers
before I came out.
Do you ever, are you like me
where you don't really start
to do the work until
you know it's due?
>> Speaker 25: Yeah.
>> Rick Riordan: I do that a lot and
so having a deadline is really good
for me, it keeps me motivated.
But, seriously, the big
motivation is you guys.
If I know that you're looking or
books to read and you're excited
and you want to read the next
adventure, that's huge motivation
for me because I want
to make you guys happy,
I want to give you guys
a book you want to read.
So that's great motivation.
>> Speaker 15: All right, we're
going to back to Sasha up here
in the upper right hand corner.
>> Speaker 26: My name is
Lena and my question is
that who is your favorite character
in the second book of Magnus Chase?
>> Rick Riordan: In the
Magnus Chase series?
Well, Magnus, of course,
he's the main character.
He's the most like me.
He has my sense of humor.
We're both kind of cynical,
both kind of sarcastic.
But I do, I do like Alex Fierro.
Alex is a really interesting
character.
I've never written anybody
quite like Alex before
and it was both a challenge and
a treat and she's really fun.
I like her.
>> Speaker 15: Okay, Stephanie
over here on the right.
>> Speaker 27: My name
is Zuri and I just wanted
to know what's your
all-around favorite god?
>> Rick Riordan: All around
favorite god, among the mythologies?
I don't know, I always liked Thor.
Thor is pretty cool.
You wouldn't know it by
the way I write about him.
I make him like this big sort
of Oaf who just kind of eats
and farts a lot but I really do
think he's a pretty cool guy.
So he's, I'd love to
have his hammer too.
That would be a great weapon.
>> Speaker 15: Okay,
back up here to the left.
>> Speaker 28: Who's your favorite
character you've ever written?
>> Rick Riordan: Favorite
character I've every written.
I mean, I'm going to have
to say Percy Jackson.
Every time I write about
him it's like going back
and seeing an old friend
all over again.
I love his voice and I
love his sense of humor.
He's a lot of fun.
>> Speaker 15: Okay,
tell us your name.
>> Speaker 29: My name is Jack
and my question is what's
the website for the quiz?
>> Rick Riordan: Yeah.
>> Speaker 29: What's
the website though?
>> Rick Riordan: Absolutely.
The website, and I don't think the
quiz is up yet but if you go there
and you bookmark it,
it'll be there soon.
The website is readriordan.com.
Read, r-e-a-d, my last
name, r-i-o-r-d-a-n.com
and there's already a bunch of
cool stuff but there's more coming.
>> Speaker 13: It's going
to go live October 17th.
>> Rick Riordan: October 17th.
>> Speaker 15: Yeah, so it's a soft
launch up now but then a hard launch
with the full gamut of what the
website offers October 17th.
Okay?
>> Rick Riordan: Cool.
All right.
>> Speaker 15: All right, Sasha, do
we have one more school question?
>> Sasha: Absolutely.
So one of our friends who is tuning
in from Brush, Colorado wants
to know, this is from
Hunter, age 10.
>> Rick Riordan: Okay.
>> Sasha: What do you think the
name of your next book will be?
>> Rick Riordan: Well I know the
one that's coming out in the spring,
that will be The Burning Maze.
That is the third book
about the trials of Apollo.
Past that I don't know.
What's coming up next for me,
the Apollo series is going
to be five books so I've
got book four and book five
and I don't know what
they're called yet.
Usually the title comes
to me right about the end
of the book I'm writing right now.
So stay tuned.
And after that I don't
know, I don't know.
Do you guys have a sense of
what you would like to see?
Like more Greek stuff or would you
like some different mythology or,
I don't know, maybe you
can tell me what you'd
like to see written about.
>> Speaker 15: Shout it out.
Anybody got any good ideas
for another book for rick?
>> Rick Riordan: Chinese.
>> Speaker 15: How about
over here, what did you say?
Okay. We're going to go one more,
we have time for one
more question right here.
>> Speaker 13: What's your name.
>> Speaker 30: Zoey.
>> Speaker 15: Zoey,
what's your question.
Shhh, hey guys, hang on, hang on.
>> Speaker 30: Why did you
want to become an author?
>> Rick Riordan: Why did I
I really like telling stories
and when I was a teacher
that's what I did.
Most of the time I would tell
stories in the classroom and so
when I started writing books
for kids it really wasn't
that much of a change.
I already liked doing that.
And I have the best job in the
world, I get to tell stories
and then come out and talk
to you guys about them.
So it's pretty cool.
>> Speaker 15: All right guys.
So let's give it up one more time
for your favorite author everybody!
Rick Riordan!
Wooh [cheers and applause]!
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.